Raymond l'abominable l'homme de Rungis
l'enfant rôdeur des kammthaar
aujourd'hui on est le 20 juin 2023 et
j'aimerais que tu te repenses à une
conversation qu'on a eu il y a un an
jour pour jour on était tous les deux en
vacances et tu te goinfrais de caviar
non
m'a dit il sortait d'une saison
incroyable de TPMP
une fois que tu es au top c'est
difficile de faire encore plus haut il
savait pas si elle allait continuer mais
cette année tu t'es surpassé après avoir
fait Billie Jean tu nous a fait thriller
à chaque intervention standing ovation
du public des répliques cultes comme
c'est nous qu'on paye
il y a aussi bien sûr on est les bonnes
la gamelle
vous allez me prendre pour un fou et
enfin ça explique la plus célèbre le
prix du gruyère il est à 95 tu es mon
abominable meilleur d'entre nous donc je
t'ai mis un